can't spin it
[Applause]
play action here steps up in the pocket
looking downfield now he'll take off and
run the whole left side of the field
wide open for Richardson touchdown
okay the defender is gonna run now this
is why route running is a big deal I
talked about it being man-to-man this
receiver is going to push this way and
then come back out he's Crosser everyone
pay attention to this corner right here
because as he sees that Crosser coming
his way see how he turns it run now now
Richardson's got all that space to go be
an athlete everybody's turned their back
to him because they think the pass
concept is Paramount and he's such a
Freakazoid athlete watch his eyes
patience hang in the pocket good
protection everybody turn their back now
let me go be a playmaker right
paid attention to the receivers and he's
such a big time run threat that it looks
like that's an easy walk-in touchdown
really good job athleticism a little bit
of the stiff arm and the jump over the
top but you see how in man coverage he
wins three for four though give this
back to Tennessee on the short field and
it could be the end of the ball game
Richardson gonna go deep and cut all the
way down to the 35-yard line of Justin
shorter play bump and run man-to-man
I'll tell you that's about as wide open
as you can be in a football game if
you're a coach
huge play on and it's getting late on
him six minutes to go
Richardson going deep down the middle
got it to shorter
boy that ball seemed to hang in the air
a long time hey you took the words right
out of my mouth free safety this way in
the middle of the field back here I
think that's him no on the other side
there's two of them and the ball's
floating and floating and floating and
he just can't get there
uh Florida's first offensive player
Richardson faked the boot he'll load it
up and cut it Loose with that big arm
Justin shorter has the long gain on the
first play touchdown Gators
Strike Up the Band where's that baller
baton
75-yard house call Richardson to shorter
they motion to tight end they go Max
protection away play comes back throws
the post out runs the secondary locks it
in the hands and he Sprints him out into
the end zone for a touchdown
Billy Napier has had high praise for
Anthony Richardson ever since the coach
arrived in Gainesville as Richardson
starts on first down in tennis is the
same play they ran last time on the
75-yard touchdown instead he'll scramble
to the sideline make an eagle Miss and
there goes 15.
Anthony Richardson is dangerous in the
open field into Eastern Washington
territory and he steps out of bounds
across Midfield here you see him coming
around actually he's very well covered
here by Eastern Washington got a missed
tackle there a little there and he's Off
to the Races Montrell Johnson is back in
the game as well good to see that he
left a couple plays ago for Florida and
the running back gets the play fake from
Anthony Richardson who loads it up again
wide open receiver is DeJean Reynolds
down the sideline inside the 30.
Richardson continues to be surgical
that's a 51-yard game but does the play
action fake as you see he starts like
he's going to roll he sits up in the
pocket here he comes the over route wide
open our boy Crosby Our Man here he
chases the post route and vacates his
Zone there
[Music]
the first team receivers two is
airs up right sideline right on the
money
touchdown Florida
Caleb Douglas
Douglas 12. 62 yards
Jalen kitten is on the board in a UF
uniform come back nice clean pocket here
okay three-step drop out of the thing
there
picks it up throws it down right on the
money in stride as he runs into the end
zone
the receiver here coming back looking
for the ball
[Applause]
makes it back look for the ball instead
of looking at his man and I've said it a
hundred times if you see the ball thrown
Drew you're going to see the ball
getting caught and that's exactly what
happened but what a throw by Jalen
kittner fourth and two
Richardson can step
[Applause]
on it the five brought down at the three
decision this goes to the fourth and two
play he drops back he's looking out to
the flat there's nothing there nothing
over the middle he feels
kind of the the defense drift apart
takes him
Richardson on second and nine his first
pass attempt to the game downfield going
for it all to the end zone
and into the hands of Justin shorter for
a Gators touchdown
let's take a look at it this is Boucher
he's going to be spying to the backhand
side you're going to see him come up and
grab underneath which allows the big
post over the top and it's a very easy
throw down the field Perfect protection
great route there by shorter
excellent drop tracking it as well
nothing Richardson looking for etm to
block which he doesn't here goes
Richardson
Ron Strider it earns his balance what a
run by Anthony Richardson Superman in
and he says I Won't Back Down
[Applause]
[Music]
with a big burst and giving Florida
somehow
now let's see how they hold up with a
guy who's most likely going to be
throwing right in the pocket that's
where he is right now and he's going
deep far side haircut
beautiful throw and catch to Justin
shorter it really was I was in perfect
phase but jumped too soon to knock it
down he's there he's there he jumps he
comes down he misjudges a perfect throw
and shorter another bit third down and
six
Georgia trying to get a stop
can't avoid any more Florida points off
that turnover Richardson all day and
rifles it down the sideline this is
Xavier Henderson and he is gone
touchdown Florida 78 yards
watch the safety he thinks it's going
short if he doesn't play The Deep man
his angle costs the touchdown
Xavier Henderson his second touchdown
Richardson
is gone off they're looking at his shoe
bottoms
Deuces touchdown
Anthony Richardson on a 60-yard bolt
across the Texas Plains
they've got wind burn trying to catch
him Robert yes boom he pulls it on his
own read he gets outside and then he
picks up and a half and he says
touchdown baby
Tennessee and or LSU could be the
beneficiaries of that written Steve
wide open
TouchDown
74-yard strike from Richardson to
Reynolds
[Applause]
Buster Ricky Wright right here he's
gonna end up with his eyes in the
backfield we talk about the play action
watch him check up
receiver runs right past him he beat
Richard off the line of scrimmage and it
was just a matter of does Richardson
have time to get the ball to him which
he certainly did and that's the big play